O
OUR PLAN TO LEAVE NO STATE
BEHIND.
THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS ARKANSAS
SENATOR TOM COTTON, AUTHOR OF
THE UPCOMING BOOK ONLY THE
STRONG, REVERSING THE LEFT'S
PLOT TO SABOTAGE AMERICAN POWER.
THE THEME OF YOUR BOOK IS THAT
THEY ARE SABOTAGING US.
THIS IS NOT BEING DONE BY
ACCIDENT, YOUR REACTION TONIGHT.
>> WHAT YOU SEE IS DECLINED BY
DESIGN.
THE LEFT HAS A 100 YEAR PLAN TO
TRY TO WEAKEN THE SOURCES OF
AMERICAN POWER.
IT GOES BACK TO WOODROW WILSON
AND THE PROGRESSIVE'S ATTACK ON
OUR DECLARATION, CONSTITUTION
AND THE MORAL FOUNDATION OF OUR
COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT A VERY FAR SLIDE TO THE
1960s AND 70s WHEN YOU HAD
THE RADICAL BLAME AMERICA FIRST
DEMOCRATS AND THE TODAY'S LEFT
IS ACTING IN THEIR SHADOW.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WANTED YOUR CAL WHY IS
INFLATION UP 13%, WHY DOES GAS
COST SO HIGH, WHY ARE YOUR FOOD
BILLS SO HIGH?
AT JOE BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS
PROMISED TO A LIMITED FOSSIL
FUELS THE SOURCE OF SO MUCH OF
OUR PROSPERITY.
IT LITERALLY POWERS OUR ECONOMY.
WHY DO WE HAVE 5 MILLION ILLEGAL
ALIENS IN OUR COUNTRY IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS?
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS
AND ELLIS OF THE DEMOCRATS
PROMISED OPEN OUR BORDER.
WHY DO DEMOCRATS CONSISTENTLY
FROM CARTER TO CLINTON TO OBAMA
TO BITE AND WEAKEN OUR MILITARY,
CONSTRAIN US WITH CRAZY
INTERNATIONAL TREATIES AND
BUREAUCRACIES -- IT'S BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT A STRONG,
SOVEREIGN AMERICA LEADING THE
FREE WORLD.
THESE ARE NOT ACCIDENTS, NOT
MISHAPS, BAD LUCK OR MISFORTUNE,
THIS IS THEIR DELIBERATE
CHOICES, THEY WANT TO WEAKEN THE
SOURCE OF AMERICAN POWER BECAUSE
THEY THINK A STRONG AMERICA IS
BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY BAD FOR THE WORLD.
>> Laura: WE HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM IN OUR MILITARY THAT
RECEIVES THE LARGEST SHARE OF
OUR BUDGET FOR SPENDING AND WE
CAN'T SEEM TO RECRUIT PEOPLE TO
THE EXTENT WE NEED TO KEEP OUR
MILITARY STRONG BECAUSE WE
DECIDED TO GO WOKE.
IT'S PART OF THEIR PLAN TO BREAK
THE MILITARY TO?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT.
>> NO QUESTION THAT HAS BEEN THE
CONSISTENT THEME YOU'VE SEEN
WITH DEMOCRATS GOING BACK TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE COLD WAR, EVEN
SO-CALLED HAWK DEMOCRATS LIKE
HARRY TRUMAN OR JFK CONSISTENTLY
CUT MILITARY SPENDING.
IT GETS WORSE OVER TIME WITH
CARTER AND CLINTON, ESPECIALLY
OBAMA AND HIS UNDERSTUDY
JOE BIDEN.
IT'S NOT JUST THE DEVASTATING
BUDGET CUTS AS WELL, IT'S THE
MISPLACED FOCUS, THAT'S ONE
REASON WHY WE HAVE THIS
RECRUITING CRISIS.
I READ A STORY THE OTHER DAY
THAT JOE BIDEN AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION ARE TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THE CAUSES OF THIS
RECRUITING CRISIS, THAT'S KIND
OF LIKE O.J. SEARCHING FOR THE
REAL KILLER.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE DEBACLE IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE FOOLISH VACCINE MANDATES,
THE RADICAL GENDER IDEOLOGY
INDOCTRINATION SESSIONS, THE
HUNT FOR SUPPOSEDLY WHITE
NATIONALIST EXTREMISTS THAT
TURNED UP NONE.
THESE ARE THE REASONS WHY WE ARE
STRUGGLING TO RECRUIT YOUNG
AMERICANS INTO OUR MILITARY.
CAN STILL JOIN THE MILITARY TO
LEARN HOW TO USE THE RIGHT
PRONOUNS, THEY LEARN HOW TO KILL
THE BAD GUYS AND THEY DON'T
THINK THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO DEFUND
THESE PROGRAMS OTHERWISE WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE OUR MILITARY.
TODAY WE LEARNED THE ARMY'S
FIRST TRANSGENDER OFFICER, MAJOR
JAMIE LEE HENDRY AND HIS WIFE
AND MARILYN DR. WERE INDICTED ON
CONSPIRACY CHARGES FOR ALLEGEDLY
ATTEMPTING TO TRANSFER
CONFIDENTIAL MILITARY MEDICAL
INFO TO RUSSIA.
QUICKLY, YOUR REACTION.
>> IT'S A VERY DISTURBING CASE,
WE WANT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT HAPPENED AND EVEN
JIM MATTIS WHEN HE WAS SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE NOT EXACTLY AN ULTRA
REPUBLICAN SAID THERE WERE A
REAL CHALLENGE IS TRYING TO
INTEGRATE TRANSGENDER PERSONS
INTO OUR MILITARY, THEY GET DOWN
TO BASIC MEDICAL SCIENCE AND
PHYSIOLOGY.
ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF HOW
DEMOCRATS PUT THEIR POLITICAL